one I went to the Billboard Music Awards
this weekend - I have not washed my hair
since I went to the Billboard Music
Awards this weekend three you can very
obviously tell that hello guys my name
is grace Helbig if you did not know now
you know your life is different now you
already know what this video is because
the title says what it is and you can
read this is the Billboard Music Awards
fashion review yes I did go to the
Billboard Music Awards they invited me
because I personify music culture you
can hear a little bit more about my
experience at the Billboard Music Awards
and how I got ready cuz I did my own
hair makeup and night warm fabrics on my
blog I have long in fact I have an
entire website of things including a
blog grace Helbig calm check it out or
don't I know I know I am so 2008 music
Fergie wasn't there so let's start
reviewing these red carpet fashion shall
we yes Demi Lovato Demi Lovato always
looks angry
60 angry she looks like she just clocked
in for work and don't [ __ ] with me
incorporated I think she looks great
because she looks great and also because
I don't want her to play with me cue
ariana grande you look like the sexy
inside of a computer I'm dialed up your
Wi-Fi is strong cuz I'm surfing boner
calm WebMD more like WebMD
she's something for that WebMD dick just
kidding what sorry when someone looks
good I turn into insecure frat boy it's
a medical thing maybe I should whip in
do your kids Lucy Hale you look like a
sexy Russian ice dancer on top and a too
sexy funeral goer on the bottom very
interesting combo I give you tens I'm
sure a couple Tonya hard-on showed up to
you why am I being Kelly Rowland you
look like the Elsa to Ariana Grande's
the other one from frozen I hope your
Wi-Fi strong enough to Google these
references Linda on
how do you pronounce your name here we
go how do you pronounce Linda
zendaya Zen day uh you don't be so judgy
about it and daya thousand at the event
and I did this I couldn't form words or
sentences and just look I just stared
directly I just blatantly and openly and
honestly with all my body and I just
stared at her because she looked so
beautiful honestly she looked even more
beautiful in person is it possible then
da-jung she look great Ashton Kutcher
looks like he's going to the sexy Civil
War sexy chimney sweep sexy character
from the Broadway musical Rent sexy
adult orphan he's given a lot of looks
and I appreciate the variety I also
appreciate tucking your pants into your
boots because you don't know when you'll
encounter snakes Meghan Trainor she
looked so good she looks like the
sparkly version of like when you're old
computers used to freeze and then an
hourglass would come up and be all like
no and usually you're like no but this
Berkeley version I'm like yeah I can
wait cute rihana you look great you look
a little bit like a sexy 80s female
stoned comedian and a little bit like
sexy Elaine from Seinfeld and a little
bit like sexy Inspector Gadget cosplay
and I don't hate any of it she don't
need no man
shiny no paint just Galba you look like
a thing you look like the good girl and
let the bad girls give her a Hot Topic
makeover Heidi Klum you look like Heidi
Klum it just looks like it's trying to
get off of your body every way possible
but you look pretty Kesha I love this
look this is an homage to Bob Dylan and
prints and oh my
I want that too you look like a sexy but
approachable Matador I'm into it dance
or dance eating what is it dudes Auggie
pronounced dude pronounced D&C I think
you guys look like you were the most
eager people at the pep rally until a
giant fire started at the pep rally you
still showed up for the game and that's
that's real guts good for you
fifth harmony this is the best funeral
I've ever been to Wiz Khalifa me app I
wish aunt dammit I wish that was me not
like the life but just that style the
other Jonas looks like the other Jonas
employed skin camel toe
mmm is happening in South America
one girl often translations out there
Britney Spears what you look great you
took all the bits on the workroom for
Project Runway and you made them work
you also somehow got a curtain stuck in
your butt on the way out the door and
that works too I love it love it love it
Shawn Mendes like I said this is the
best funeral I think I've ever attended
Laverne Cox palsy 101 should be my
friend - you look like an ish your
pending that I'm okay being lost in Pete
Wentz yeah dude Michael Strahan doing
the bestie strake am busy sterling look
at this angel sent from Evan you look
classy look sexy you look mermaidy you
look gorgeous god dammit seal looks like
a six-year-old boy that tried on all the
Stan's quotes and is not self-aware
enough to know that they don't fit
Rihanna you just look so pretty
now laptop bag stuff that is very
millennial Steven Tyler I just I want
what I won't I want I want to be I want
one people when they see me to see that
my camera shut off which is probably for
the best
I think I was malfunctioning troye sivan
like it boo boo look at this look at
this and look at this pleated pants on
the silk
how dare you make what every skeezy guy
in the 90s in Miami wore look adorable
there you go there my thoughts on the
Billboard Music Awards fuchsia carpet
fashions everyone looked alive I know I
didn't cover everyone that you might
want to be - that was on the future
carpet and I'm sorry but there's just
too many people to talk about if you
want to hear more about my look go over
to my blog for a selfie comm check it
out and don't forget to subscribe if you
enjoy these videos
he's got button right there and then we
can be connected I'm getting closer and
closer to 3 million subscribers and I
just really want to pass it let me know
who your favorites add the Billboard
Music Awards and I don't know see la la
this looks like this looks like